for more than 400 million years sharks
have been vital to the health of our
oceans
sharks are apex predators
by balancing food webs and keeping prey
populations healthy
sharks keep ecosystems healthy
with all these all these sharks around
the submarine
sharks have such an important role in
the ecosystem they keep
the ocean ecosystem imbalance and
with sharks go that's the first sign of
the degradation of the entire food chain
what we find in these remote places
around the world is that apex predators
really
dominate and drive the function of the
whole ecosystem
in pristine places we have an inverted
biomass pyramid where there's more
predators than prey and these predators
control the whole ecosystem
this top-down controlled ecosystem is
really what makes pristine places unique
yet that's what all places used to look
like before humans remove these large
animals from the ocean biggest threat to
sharks is overfishing
sharks are killed and sold for luxuries
like shark fin soup
sharks they've been around for
over 400 million years they've survived
several mass extinctions yet they are
being removed at rates that are
outpacing their ability to reproduce
90 of these large animals have been
fished with the absence of these apex
predators marine ecosystems could
collapse
but there's a proven solution
marine protected areas
these are areas where fishing and other
damaging activities are prohibited
helping to protect the ocean's
biodiversity and creating a safe haven
for sharks
it's much easier to protect a place
that's healthy than it is to try to fix
a place after it's broken
[Music]
[Music]
you